[Music]
[Music]
listening to all the things you can tell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your hearts running away with your head
I thought it all happened it just
wouldn't work
[Music]
[Music]
cancer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it begins on a dark night look at this
you're not gonna find another girl like
her in a million years
[Music]
it's also magical London I've never
fallen apart that first Sunday
ever done I've never before
that first Sunday
[Music]
I read way I am NOT going back and I am
NOT going back I ran away I am NOT going
back
let's make some magic
[Music]
[Music]
dr. bar
[Music]
Hospital
your frog
there's this girl
[Music]
it's not time in my life job you
[Music]
I ran away
not going back I am NOT going back you
should you should
I ran away and I am NOT going back and I
am NOT going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
didn't care of them haha
[Music]
[Music]
wonderful
I
[Music]
someday
[Music]
that's all goodbye thank you goodbye
[Music]
she's sideways
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hope everything's okay
[Music]
empty the money in the cash register
now mr. Duchin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. pumpers
[Music]
a TV
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. company
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey there we go welcome to the
presidential press briefing it's the
press it's at the press briefing I just
realize do we need the microphone on
this side if I'm gonna be turning to
Gerald we should be good okay live
stream just so you know we're not gonna
it's not like the Oscars stream or
whatever other award what other streams
have we done Oh CNN fact check with all
due next Thursday we want to do the job
that the media isn't doing namely
broadcasting the briefing from the
President of the United States
especially considering the executive
order yeah this week regarding AB well
today yesterday today yesterday
immigration we're 20 I'm as a funny
thing sorry I'm a little distracted
because I hear Betty barking on the
promo code by the way is quarantine to
get $30 off huge I does mug Club
quarantine is the hashtag do we have a
hashtag for the stream today not for
this okay but we do have some drinking
game Rory by the way bring them up there
audio wave cuz I can't see what they are
the number one rule is every time Trump
says China you have to drink Twitter and
then number two drink twice if POTUS
destroys a reporter two rules yeah where
you from
smack Ville drink destroyed so we
exported a little bit of the Don Rickles
you should go live in Poughkeepsie with
with the broom call him your wife what
he says what you talk about John Rickles
I've never wanted to watch a briefing
more in my life though he does them
they're hilarious
I never sometimes I agree with them
sometimes I disagree with what he says
but they're always funny and
entertaining and sorry we started late
but we started late because our
president can't be bothered to be on
time you know what do we expect here
today what do you expect your jailed you
know I'm gonna well I plan I realized I
should place this on well you probably
ought to right so I I expect a I expect
to get a for him to get a lot of
pushback on the executive order that he
issued I think that will probably be one
of the biggest
hapax conversation because it's the
easiest punch to throw at him right now
sure
and then they'll follow that up with the
reopening and the challenges with that
and then probably I don't know I don't
if there's somebody with some balls in
the room they'll ask about this study
that came out of California and so we'll
see yeah friend time somebody has any
hutzpah they will ask that question I
just don't know that that's actually
gonna happen and we'll say just so you
know we are not streaming CNN CBS ABC
we're streaming directly from the White
House so if we get taken down you know
that everyone here will be voting Biden
White House don't take us down we're
here to help
yes so what do I expect here today and I
get the promo code is quarantine
tomorrow we have Dan crunch on the show
by though yes and then Ted Cruz on
Thursday getting a lot of guests a
patriotic week people get a little bit
pissed off you know I just rightfully so
I think we are going to look back on
this time and go gosh what a massive
overreaction so much I don't know if you
can even go to the HuffPo homepage
they're given but um who wants to do
that today I suppose in the long-term
effects of kovin 19 on the body and then
it was Kovan 19 is child's play compared
to what's coming down the pike and so
why are you talking about what's in the
pipes sure or what's in a headline
there's no antique Ovid yeah Sal right
now in the pike still there that's
primarily we're dealing with but they
want to move on because I'll get to a
couple minutes before we can't talk
about what treats it no that would be
well we can talk about wait that's
racist and this is by the way so this I
think this is important the fact that
and I bet you they're going to bring
this up with Donald Trump by the way the
executive order with Mexico to me is
just a three crises oh they start is
that them them I'm not seeing anything
right now it's probably I hate you
autoplay lady who looks like she just
got out of the shower
Stephen she's real yeah anyway go to
HuffPo you able to see the headline so
with the executive order some people are
saying well how can you be against the
lockdown but want to lock down the
borders well because I don't think that
we should shut our country down and
simultaneously have open borders yeah I
understand
might be a little bit of I think that we
should have the country the economy open
but not the borders checkmate no no no
no we should open the country in an
orderly reasonable way right as you see
with president Trump's rephase sort of
guidelines we can't be letting people
flood through the borders at all well
and also not every country has the same
kind of lockdown strategy that we've had
they've not all had the same success
containing the virus that we have and so
somebody could come in and get past all
the screening and start off another wave
so you don't want to necessarily that
that happened anyway so I don't think
it's a bad thing to limit immigration
right now and open the economy at the
same time well you think you don't
really happen it's more symbolic sure
but I love the symbol yeah and the
symbolism is basically like it's it's
the apparatus from seven for the sin of
lust
oh that's basically what the symbolism
is he did now Ted is Donald Trump is
saying
all right listen okay you want to play
all right yeah I'm gonna put it use an
executive order on immigration yeah it's
more appropriate than a lot of executive
executive orders that could be enacted
but I don't think it's going to be long
term and this is just again to get them
to go absolutely nuts but it is amazing
to me this is one thing ID works every
time lawyers the fact that it was front
page everywhere okay if we're all in
this together then we should all be
celebrating together when we get good
news right right
if we go back someone can maybe put
together one image for the first time we
talked about this we said hey listen oh
and by the way I forgot live chat you
were live chatting of course at the
blaze we're not doing live chat super
chat on YouTube because YouTube doesn't
pay us anything
no they pay pants very little oh yeah so
it's not nothing but it's not a little
bit here oh oh zero yeah absolutely but
but they but they they they pay us and
goodwill realize that's nice oh my gosh
so we should all be celebrating good
news together by the oh shoot I gotta
get a hand I got rid of the ban like a
philistine us somebody don't worry
stirring up it's a limited release from
one lot no they know I wanted Garage WA
and I said to my oh hey
lovely isn't it I got Trump right over
my left shoulder so we should all be
celebrating good news together well
here's the thing and I talked about this
with Ben Shapiro before we was talking
about the mortality rate I said well
second the mortality rate really isn't a
consistent measurement we have to look
at overall deaths you say yeah but
that'll that'll just go or say sorry I
said deaths per million right deaths per
capita per capita death and you actually
couldn't go per capita deaths any lower
than a million is that the starting line
what is for this oh can someone search
what capita means you can do per
thousand Oh exactly
yeah but yeah to start at a million
otherwise it wouldn't even show up on
the graph sure yes so if you look at the
deaths per capita that's what really
matters because you can't just say total
deaths in the United States and prepared
to say you know Botswana I have no idea
but I assume they're probably not great
and well the probably when there is no
kovat going on and there's there's not
as many people in Botswana last I
checked I don't know that was the
initial point I was making Korea glad we
got there so that's the number that
Maddon clarify and I know Ben told me
said you know that number is only going
to go up yeah sure
but it's also going to go up with other
countries by the way surprisingly not
really going up and Sweden the way that
most people thought would be happening
because they didn't enact some kind of
water damage so Italy Spain Belgium I
don't know about Belgium sorry but Italy
Spain France and of course they're
actually hit the worst and we're doing
far better than them but the mortality
rate changes the more infections that
you see right now to me it would seem to
be good news when you say oh my gosh way
more people have been infected than we
initially great writers a lot because
that means the mortality rate is far
lower and most people are in symptomatic
what is yeah I was watching CNN and they
actually talked about that this being
right now you watch CNN and they were
talking about
well it sounds sounds like there are
more infections than we ever thought as
if that were a bad thing yeah but but
obviously it doesn't change the en you
are such a disease we in an airport look
what you France tell Korea what the
French call lazy incompetent and gay
love it oh but explain with that why
that would be a good thing because it
lowers the mortality rate so let me
bring this up actually have these
numbers here today this is a study by
the way from USC and of course Los
Angeles the Public Health Department not
necessarily a bastion like I don't think
they're funded by
rush limbaugh no USC they look for
antibody tests now keep in mind there
are two different things okay and this
is really really good news now still be
reasonable still obviously we need to
protect the most vulnerable among us
every single life lost obviously matters
and is tragic and we feel for them and
the nine eleven firefighters first
responders NYPD after September 11th
nothing compared to the nurses right now
they are are zeros no not even
comparable name me any other can't do it
nothing even comes to mow yeah Nelson
Mandela nope nope Martin with incredible
hole now maybe I'm sure I'm trapped
between a not wanting to remove from
YouTube and a racist place responders
all agree absolute scum compared to the
nurses and doctors of today absolute
subhuman scum the first responders of
9/11 compared again context matters
compared to the first responders today
who do so of their own free will with
and it hasn't put a nickel in their
pocket yeah all right I want to say that
you you want to walk one no I don't want
to walk this back I'm saying that you
won't be happy if they would celebrate
that news I would be happy if they
actually reported it out there I don't
need a ticker tape parade for it I want
to make sure they have this this right
here day so this comes from USC in Los
Angeles Public Health Department okay
they did an antibody test now what does
that mean someone may not test positive
for coronavirus fork over 19 but if you
test for antibodies you can then see how
many people have had it at some point
right examine oh and I found this out at
one point where I was like I think I
have mono yeah doctor said well test
really isn't gonna help us that's what
it means to just tell me that you have
mom that you had mono scientific because
the only test that he had if it was the
antibody test at his place I'm not sure
that's when I learned about antibodies
that imagine little bus and that little
that little prick knew he should have
stayed home today but he didn't he never
does never does follow your gut
Ralph whatever well stop talking about
it was it Ralph I think so I think it
was rough
Ralph Ralph
so back to the USC they looked for
antibodies right and they saw they said
oh this actually looks like it's between
I think two point eight and what five
point six percent of the people in Los
Angeles County actually had anybody's
which means the number is twenty eight
to fifty what 28 256 something like that
528 255 times higher the infection rate
than they thought that means that at the
low end a minimum using the sample stage
shows that 220,000 people in Los Angeles
County had had kovat and at the high end
over 400,000 so let's just take those
numbers and split them right down the
middle 600 deaths total in Los Angeles
County
so that means when you just take the
total deaths by the way just the total
deaths and you look at the actual
infection rate again this comes from USC
and they really really don't want this
to be the case and the owners right
yesterday yes and that's what page news
everywhere when that's a an exception to
the rule right whereas now we are
actually getting enough data to
determine what the rule is
it hasn't been trending it hasn't been
reported anywhere so if you just take
those numbers use the middle numbers
let's play conservatively that means
that the death rate at the worst is 0.25
the mortality rate you take into account
people have actually had it now let's
use these numbers I think in Italy when
it was 95 to 98% of people who
contracted the disease who were deaths
they were over the age of 80 or they had
some pre-existing condition if I'm not
mistaken in New York it was high 80s and
some figures that were cited to 90
something percent let's play it really
conservatively and say ok only 80% of
the Cova deaths at this point only 80%
are from old people or people with
pre-existing conditions that gives you a
death rate meaning if you are an average
aged middle-aged above middle age of
average health american right now in
this country your chances of dying from
kovin 19 if you get it is 0.02 percent
Wow Wow from zero point zero point to
likely zero point one to zero point zero
two let's call it zero let's just call
it zero point one well let's just go
with zero point one a nice round number
because you know you have to do a point
you have to add a zero a fee it's
difficult to point we don't have the
math or do as a decimal point well and
that's it's funny that we make sure that
daughters because
I'm tired I just say ellipsis and that's
fine but 0.1 what is it that that's the
influenza death rate every year is point
one right six point zero six okay so I'm
not super far off on that but all of a
sudden you start to see that this has a
much lower far more comparable than
people led you to believe it's not
saying open everything it's not the same
thing I could be responsible that's not
what anybody is saying but that's all
here's the thing that's not what the
president is saying no nobody is
nobody's saying that we should just open
up and go right back to the way we were
what we're saying is that you can open
certain things up and take precautions
and still live life we live life every
single day under the threat of dying
right our whole existence is to not die
everybody we have shelter we have safety
features and cars to keep us from dying
and so we can surely manage a situation
like this what are we supposed to do
lock down everything forever I mean
really because here's the concern the
concern is that it's just like 1918
where it came out in the spring it was
not nearly as deadly it came back in the
fall and people didn't respond
appropriately right okay I think it
should be noted this isn't just a lone
study it actually tracks with we covered
this a while back to Santa and showed a
similar number yeah so at the very least
the infection rates on the low side are
minimum 28 to 30 times higher than we
thought likely 40 something times higher
than we thought which is also why you
have to throw out we have the most
infections what were the biggest country
that's testing that much at this point
right yeah throw out this how many
hospitalizations and also some it's
pretty funny to me not I should say not
funny all tragedy we shouldn't laugh we
shouldn't react to our lives you should
feel guilty for even watching this and
even we're being alive the slightest
sliver of entertainment shame on you
shame on you I shouldn't be having this
cigar how dare you and it's your
favorite cigar but the point here is I
don't even know what my point was I just
one criticism of Trump has been that
he's been talking about raw numbers so
saying like this is how many masks we
have this is how many ventilators we
have and the crit numbers well the
criticism has been that we don't that
he's not giving how many we need so we
don't know where those numbers are
headed but if they don't but they're
doing the exact same thing back
yes but there's done that and then I
just excoriate him so a good example
when they said you know Cuomo said they
needed was a comer de Blasio to the
needed 40,000 ventilators I think he was
wrong right where Donald Trump said
where they need 40,000 ventilators most
hospitals don't have we need to look
into what's happening with these
ventilators they said look he's trying
too strong on the states and I sure hate
them they topped out that 4,000 I didn't
even use them all oh that's what I was
going to get to it we have this right
now I just went out on Twitter remember
they were saying initially if you think
you have Co bid 19 what do they say if
you were young and you have symptoms
stay holy homes do not go to the
emergency room today lo and behold at
CNN they say people are waiting way too
long to go to the hospital come on
what do you want me to do because and
they're afraid of catching it of course
because you told me stay home and then
you had to layoff health care workers
you had to furlough workers because
there wasn't this this storming of the
hospitals right that's right what that
we thought there would be and now they
have to say well listen you need it you
need to go you didn't get the hospital
right away and what really bothers me
about this - I will say is I saw an
article on Huffington Post today so I
expect all of this coming from the
reporters because Huffington Post CNN or
one the same that's a silver lining here
they really didn't want you to forget
about koban 19 going into the election
in in Jamie 20 guess what neither do i I
want you to remember this matter of fact
I want you to remember this come fourth
of July I want you to remember all of
this look back on it set a date in your
calendar right now look at all the
restrictions all the Liberty that you've
given up as an American and then see if
they were worth it and then they try to
tell you that you are basically a Nazi
sympathizer if you protest governor
Whitmer who by the way doesn't want to
allow you to go buy a poinsettia so you
can buy a poor kilogram of we for a car
seat right for a newborn baby to take
them home from the hospital and these
people protest it and you put them in
cars now they're going talk they're
going out looking telephone poles right
they're driving in their car friend it
seems to me that if we are concerned
about the safety of Americans you would
want car seats for children because far
more children are harmed I would imagine
an automobile accidents then will die
from copa90 yeah but and and I think
you're right what is governors whitmer
says screw screw it fits on a shirt well
yeah this is a picture of a car seat and
it's governor Whitmer saying
[Laughter]
we've got all the hell we know are you
kidding me what else do we have here oh
uh Andrew Cuomo's said today that New
York hospitalizations basically flat the
overall curve is on the way down and by
the way who knows where the curve would
be if they didn't add and you know what
3,700 extra deaths that we didn't ask
for but we think our kovat right yeah
and what the word they've been using for
that on CNN is presumed right because oh
it's like okay well it's in there saying
may be diagnosed later diagnosed or
presumed what a shame we can we can
mister if you can do maybe on deaths we
can do maybe on infections and make it
even a little bit even it's not maybe
it's a study from USC use their words
their standard that is right now there
is no accountability what will happen
they'll move on to keep in mind you know
what what's happening right before
Corona and I mean before it became
obviously the sort of pandemic that we
know it as now so we have to go back
even before de Blasio and Nancy Pelosi
were saying you're stupid it's out in
Chinatown this was happening right
before that does anyone remember those
impeachment yeah it was non-stop
impeachment remembered it was before
that it was Russia gate yeah do you
really member what were the main story
was before that it really it was
Kavanagh it went Kavanagh and then
Russia non-stop Russia which Milton now
coronavirus right that's true you want
to tell me that none of this is designed
to try and drag this guy down going into
2020 someone people say he shouldn't be
bringing up any of this for 2020 well
first off I think that he's brought a
lot of information is to try and correct
the media but you know what you guys are
trying to just this is entirely
politicized if you were trying to
destroy his chances in 2020 because you
have a man with early-onset dementia who
doesn't tell the difference between a
vase and his house cat then he has the
right I think he absolutely has the
right to defend himself and that's why I
loved the video that he put on for the
press and he kind of pointed like you
said a few times any other president
that's you I like that shirt looks
better than this shirt I think he has
every right to punch back and
times he does it in a way that maybe we
don't love and sometimes we absolutely
eat it up because it's like that's
exactly what they deserve
they deserve to have their nose rubbed
in the crap that they've been peddling
for so long but none of them win you
don't rub your dog's nose and crap you
rub it in pee is that what you did when
you dogs in it hopper he did it real
close yeah you don't rub his nose in it
he pooped on me the second time so yeah
no no he was fine monkey see monkey do
he just got me out of edit to learn it
Gerald
nobody's rubbing hoppers nose in
anything that he didn't so well I won't
do it I promise okay but but anyway they
deserve that they really do because they
have not done their job and it's not
only that they've not done their job
when they're called out on it they turn
a blind eye to it I really don't
understand the psychology behind this
like how do you see very clearly a
timeline and then pivot over here to
something else like you it has to be
nefarious at that paulus I could really
don't understand the psychology I don't
I don't understand how you can I don't
know how you can balance two things sure
one saying you're absolutely after
balance is right you could balance three
things jerk I was pointing that it was
only two all right so you could balance
on the one hand saying that you are the
voice of truth right you would be more
apt it would be like but you can say on
one hand that you're after drawing a
balance these cute three three I did Oh
Oh No but on the one hand saying that
you're after truth right and that you
are for the American people and on the
other hand ignoring at every single turn
obvious facts yeah right and it's exact
same thing that you could declare that
Trump is doing himself obvious good news
well in that they've been able to unable
to say that China has any amount of
responsibility for this shows that just
from using one way keep in mind like
good news a lot of the time any day you
can say that Trump is a bombastic ass
right right far be it for me to disagree
with you but the problem is you are
consistently pushing bad news and so he
seems like the eternal optimist where he
goes I don't know why they need 40,000
ventilators what are you saying is it's
not that bad
we're gonna send them what with what
they actually need right they go how
dare you
turns out they only need four thousand
ventilators we're not gonna see we're
not gonna see the same kind of like we
built these hospitals they're not using
these hospitals right now they're
shutting them down how dare you turned
out they weren't actually only filled to
capacity with hospitals right now he's
going you'll assume that the death rate
is going to be a lot lower as we
increase testing how dare you I'm amazed
that we can't actually sanitize these
masks we have some very fine liquids how
the best live now in a thousand a day
masks recyclable can be sanitized how
right dare you how dare you how dare you
any time he tries to present a sliver of
hope and I will say to the media I hate
saying how dare you but I will ask you
why do you present for example I start
Huffington Post where said generation Z
their home long before I could ever
start because they don't know a world
and they don't their whole life I seize
hold on a second bad okay first off do
we even think this is nearly as bad as
9/11 I don't but then if you want to say
this is this is so much worse than the
greatest generation had it can you
imagine that for a second can you
imagine being 15 years old right before
World War two and your dad saying I know
you're only 15 but you're gonna be going
into mandatory service and guess what
all of Europe yeah it's not Europe
anymore okay the only thing that stands
between us and these fascist bastards by
the way and maybe it could be communist
because we don't know what's gonna work
out but either way we're gonna end up
with fascism or communism and them both
so I want to be coming over the ocean
puffin holding stopping them at this
point is Winston Churchill so I'm gonna
take you to the shooting range right now
so you can hopefully get proficient
before you get thrust onto the beaches
where you have a mortality rate to kind
of I won't even tell you about it
because it will send shivers down your
spine you want to compare that and say
that that is nothing in contrast to
today's and I know that we shouldn't be
belittling it but let's be honest here
it's not even close and if generation Z
feels entirely hopeless thank the Lord
above they were not the ones storming
the beaches of Normandy well if
Generation Z is watching CNN if
Generation Z is watching the modern
media or staying on Twitter for much
brian Stelter hills and that demo i hope
i hope so but if they're watching that
then of course they're gonna feel like
the world is constantly
but but these but these worldwide things
like rolling - yeah his worldwide things
like World War 2 weren't really felt on
the ground in the CIA and just because
every single day CNN wants you to feel
like you're in crisis but right if I
limited yourself to sort of what's going
on immediately around you life's pretty
good yeah like first up Generation Z is
the least affected in the sense in the
least affected health-wise they're the
most affected affected as far as the
economic ripples right that's the thing
that and they're going to start singing
up flying when they realize that and
start looking for jobs yeah and a
hyperventilation by the way the entire
economy is gonna be changing I think the
thing that we'll see most change on
probably automation and sort of this
merging of Tech and Industry because I'm
kind of had one foot in one foot out for
a little while as for sweep accelerate
that you'll see generation Z be furious
ones have to enter the workforce but
health-wise they're the least at risk
your your great-grandfather some of you
grandfather's they had to storm the
beaches of one of the most powerful
military forces rootless military forces
ya ever in the history of mankind you
have to put on gloves and a mask if
you're really careful when you go pick
up your order at Papa John's if you
can't spare the uber each 250 delivery
surcharge and just to clarify it's not
that gin gin Z has lived with the most
chaos and and and disasters they lived
with the most manufactured chaos right
right they haven't lived I mean put
yourself in the shoes of somebody who
had to live through World War one the
global flu pandemic that pretty much you
you think this is bad shutting things
down
that was crazy great times in the 20s
Great Depression in the 30s and World
War two in the 40s yeah you're telling
me that this is the same as that the
Jill's ears and that had a crisis to
deal with a knock tail no standard
hoochie couldn't show you how to make it
sort of a because there were no no grow
knees right and by the way stanley tucci
is full of crap and the Garonne e is the
easiest cocktail to make he's not a
mixologist one ounce gin one ounce sweet
vermouth one ounce can Perry that's it
you don't even even have bitters people
like oh oh this is but this is what I
didn't know that I needed right now we
really affected take that to G take that
too yeah we know you're watching
my point is is that this pandemic
affects older generations more than gin
Z anyways yeah so what are you
complaining about right now get go away
BuzzFeed stop doing your [ __ ] whoa
whoa sorry the articles like geez
everything is negative everything is
negative like can we look on the bright
side of any of this I'll tell you what's
negative is that you added a little bit
of a Sicilian alil to when you said
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh Gino doing
Jimmy Hoffa as much like Jimmy Hoffa
equally sound like Jimmy Hoffa
well which which one he did the voice
differently multiple yeah why do you be
the other one not really sure do we know
by the way has there been the vote yet
on the the small business relief bill I
haven't seen the results of that no so
that was supposed to be voted on an hour
ago
I don't know if we have the results
because we're getting here ready to do
the live show when someone can let us
know should have signed a week ago but
they shouldn't have listened and I
understand it's not just they're trying
to block because the Deaf let's be
honest the Democrats would love to spend
this money right they would love to give
us - so they're blocking it because they
want to shoehorn in some other frivolous
rap you know that's blocking if
immigration is banking it's sake they're
like oh you you need something from us
okay well for the right to say you don't
care about small businesses the fact is
what what bothers me more is that the
left when you'll see them with these uh
this reporting right now is they don't
want people to be able to make a living
right they want them to think the right
part it's for the greater good to not be
able to make a living which is crazy to
your part all businesses all jobs are
essential for the people who rely on
them for a livelihood yeah
tell someone why can't put food on the
table for my family well it's not
essential so the government wants to
replace what is essential with
government checks with government
stimulus check never I mean Andrew yang
would do that for the rest of his life
even though he tries to point to it
working in Alaska you're really talking
about a few bucks and a cup of coffee a
month and I'm sorry about a thousand
dollars there's no opportunity Alaska is
not representative of the rest of the
United own even have the same genetics
that's Steven we do have an update oh
wait the Senate approves four hundred
eighty billion dollar package to help
small businesses and hospitals expand
system
and I guarantee supers gonna go out a
new version i'ma go out we did this for
you America we fought with the
Republicans and we got you the best deal
Pommery oh my gosh really again you know
what the whole pizza gay thing obviously
was it was a propaganda thing was a hoax
it wasn't true okay so I'm not gonna be
peddling that here but I will say you
didn't need to go with the lie it's
enough that Schumer looks like Lemony
Snicket's yeah no one's gonna try and
shoot up a pizza parlor looking for kids
in the basement that doesn't exist just
you know say their looks and Lemony
Snicket's that's enough that you could
just move on from there so 480 billion
dollar a day that's that's good
okay that's needed it was needed a week
ago there are a lot of people right now
that don't make the week oh it's
something I hope someone asks or Donald
Trump talks about this remember the yes
swastika at the Trump rally yeah we're
talking about at the healthcare
healthcare at the the shutdown protest
rally it was from a burning rally from a
while ago oh well every almost every
time you hear a story about a swastika
this is what I've learned as it relates
to swastikas if a story centers around a
swastika having been created in the last
20 years it's not true oh yeah
Stephen believed made in poop in times
out of 10 they're backwards yes that's
true and believe all stories yeah you
put poop on the wall up on the world
yeah a trained monkey from a white
supremacist I don't think like I don't
think they would paint a swastika and
poop right that's like guys a redneck
that has a redneck confederate and he's
wiping his ass with a confederate flag
it doesn't compute dude he's using it
dry humping the robert e lee statue he's
honoring it yeah
not again so I don't know they're still
they're always running late these yeah
yeah there's still the government and
this is what bothers me about screens
this is why I hate screens in every
single restaurant nowadays I'm watching
this stream yeah it's a completely
useless screen and you go to a bar now
and every single bar determines that
they have to have television screens
because god forbid that we talk to each
other in our friend
screener isn't enough rule we were kids
how cool we thought it would be to have
a portable TV now we have a portable
everything and we still look at the
screens
it just says live stream starting soon
I've seen so much Saturday Night Live
that I think somebody's gonna come on
and say and now the president will
address the exactly that somebody's
gonna talk but it's definitely something
that I've learned from do you know how
Alec Baldwin does his Donald Trump
compression please tell me six figures
and hair and makeups nothing else a
little bit about the list very beginning
of the the his presidency and even when
he was running and becoming kind of a
main contender your impression was so
good I was like he's gonna take off like
somebody's gonna come and get him and
then they took Alec Baldwin for us and I
was like oh that's there's some insane
baseball you know about the SNL audition
right know what as you like what can I
never have is that again oh you trick
you're not gonna get the best of all
find the rapper over here and I know
they actually so we sent in some
impressions and we sent in sup because
we were told to actually communicate
with someone and send up a deep I think
we had to send a physical DVD and I
never yeah nothing happened but what did
have the ones with a Jon Stewart thing
where they said hey do you have anyone
like this steven crowder guy but like
like you know not him like I'm a liberal
yeah that point work with a lot of
comedians who were correspondents on The
Daily Show Noah the good course I wanted
to yeah the real musical what do you
mean they're like well we don't really
have like political people on classic
what do you mean you know political
because like we don't like just like we
like that he's young we like that you
know but like do you have like something
similar but not him and then when I
released the email I think it was back
on the YouTube channel it may have been
removed from the Vox ad pocalypse purge
uh what happened was uh he dropped me
and my manager was a conservative by the
way he had an agreement he said like hey
listen they're putting a lot of pressure
on me I said listen Andy I won't give
you his last name I said I understand
frankly I don't know I think there's a
whole lot you can do for me now at this
point anyway because I had a contract
with Fox News at that point I was
starting up and I had a contra so I said
you know what that's fine let's just and
we're still friends
let's but um yeah so I've had that I've
had that happened but I I guarantee you
that they would not be fans of my Donald
impression because I think it's it's not
even in the same ballpark as Alec
Baldwin that in the Bernie impression
those are probably my favorites no stop
it it is it is you have my favorite
impression that you do is Gerald Wayne I
knew it
you might need to work on it a little
bit for you pulling out any timeline
name I thought it was maybe it's a lot
of work on it so again the promo code is
quarantine you get $30 a year you get
your get you will get $30 off using the
promo uses getting through the month of
April yes and I think it's a lot of a
lot of municipalities extended their
stay at home order told me they really
really well we're does that mean you
have to do more good morning Mudd Club
interesting I think with as as Trump
does pull back a lot of this the sort of
restrictions you start introducing the
word you were looking ya the curtain
yeah yeah so as as he pulls back the
restriction curtain yes it'll be
interesting to see how different states
respond to that yeah and see if they
ramp up or yeah if we actually see
federalism in action or if we just see
people whatever I was gonna say I think
they should respond differently Florida
should respond differently than New York
should respond differently than
California assess and differently though
I think the rest of the country should
respond differently and that they should
like Yukon kornelius where there's own
little iceberg we should just axe pick
all of Manhattan and push it off into
the ocean I think if we all push we
could make some progress I mean they
have a significant economy they can fend
for themselves they came close to
separating why not Manhattan not even
the boroughs want you lift the bridges
that's terrible it's not that terrible
no for them yeah imagine being trapped
on the island once you've been pushed
off I mean that's I guess but I don't
tell geology works but we can oh it's
fine drift yes sir I think you may not
know possibly happen and by the way the
Canarsie gave that away for what was it
60 60 guilders worth whatever was the
old term it was like a ship held so that
I think was a Canarsie Brooklyn there
were a couple of tribes that sort of
were in Manhattan
they've never concept of personal
property talk about the one that got
away yeah
that little island that you thought
nobody wanted sure appreciated in value
all that happened was a little bit of a
little bit of air travel a little bit of
more sophisticated boats than yours I
mean canoes and all the sudden we get
our check every month they walk into
Manhattan and they're like there's no
farmland here where there's no and we
have to travel across a river it's a
terrible you think there would have been
like one Canarsie who had an annoying
mother-in-law on the other side of the
river and just wanted to stay in
Manhattan like plan is flat when you pry
this island from my cold dead fingers
I'm sorry my pelts are so nice anywhere
else
[Laughter]
wait that happens what are they bringing
something up okay so uh what else do we
have here we have a couple of things
that I wanted to get to and you just
keep talking we'll just keep talking the
promo code is warranty no we're not
going to be doing we made use it you
know what let us know if you want some
more good morning Muslim we may do half
and half of the late-night in the
morning stuff some of you guys like us
doing the morning stuff it's a little
more relaxed we hit stories a little bit
earlier in the day but yeah the ones
yeah it's fun but when I'm tired like
from doing this and I'm not listen
here's the thing I'm not complaining I'm
very grateful but the reality is I'm
obviously a little bit course hired the
first thing to go is my executive
functioning and in my short-term memory
that's how I sound a little Biden ish
like I can still get out there perform
what does happen is I will forget my
train of thought a little bit and you
ever get that point where it's like like
I realized yesterday do you guys ever
get this where you're it's that wired
and tired where you're too tired to do
anything but you're also bored with
doing this yes yeah I understand exactly
what you mean I don't think when you lay
down to try and relax
you can't your brain is still going and
that's I think the boredom part and I
feel like Donald Trump deals with those
moments by tweeting and Biden just does
it without his brain going at all yes
yes
shut down manually Biden horse drink
salt water say no you're supposed to
focus soak the afflicted area bones
drinking it doesn't send it to your
brain
eucalyptus do with the foul Qi thing cuz
he'll be up here people are calling him
a rock star and they have some people
saying fire foul cheat you know what I'm
not on either of those no guys I think
he has some valuable insight I think he
has some important insight but people do
need to remember
I think it's on pause by the way so we
want to know people do need to remember
that he isn't a business owner in the
same way he isn't an economist you can't
only ask a healthcare expert for example
when we were building this new when we
were building this new studio with
people who are specialized and they're
like well we want to do this with
lighting and this was lighting we're
going on second we have to make sure
that the sound works that lighting grid
doesn't really work first of all we want
to do this with the air we're going on
second we actually have to have offices
here we have to have an edit Bay here
sometimes people who think only in line
with their vertical and that's why
specialists are really valuable but
that's also why you don't make them a
captain of a ship
you don't have a Spock as a captain you
need a Kirk and so I think that voci is
very valuable but him when he starts
getting out of his Lane a little bit but
no you said no we just prefer Picard
part all right I'm so is he the gay guy
hey gay it's sir
nothing wrong with it nothing has
improved I would still receive him the
same amount which is religiously is he
actually gay no no I think everyone
thinks he's just friends with gay people
I mean he just kind of thank you for
clarifying
Instagram a necking session with I think
that's what he's a performance to keep
us guessing so I think that coaching is
sustaining is laying a little bit he
does he does and and and and by the way
you also do have to go back to balancing
right or juggle have anything maybe
balance people's livelihoods and
people's lives and that's why it is
relevant information that it's a point
0.2 to 0.02 percent mortality rate with
this disease that is relevant because I
guarantee you if you give the American
public that information and you make
sure that you deliver it
on an ongoing basis they aren't going to
act like these people are effectively
you know commie sympathizers out there
and Nazi sympathizers who are saying hey
I want to go back to work driving around
Lansing in their SUV right well and
without to you I mean people the media
basically pulled him from his role as a
doctor into the role of you tell us what
we should do about everything with the
economy right right and the country
that's not the role that I think he even
wanted to be in and and that's
definitely not a role that we want a
doctor in it and I don't think you know
it's fair to say he's a rock star or
that he should be fired because the same
people were saying both of those things
depending on the day and depending on
what he said and how it aligned with
their views of the crisis right right
right and so it was just it was very
disingenuous to me to hear them say he's
the best listen to him and then he would
say something too they disagree with and
they're like oh we got a [ __ ] pouchy
I'm like what right the same person who
said him and I will say wrong they
really disappointed in a lot of
conservatives out there who so willingly
gave up liberties so quickly I agree and
I don't mean everybody's like listen yes
social putting in a responsible order
telling people they should stay at home
when possible of course but shutting
down businesses or fining people or
arresting people for public displays of
affection with their spouses in parks or
getting on a bus jog on a baby alone
when you look I do think this is really
important right now because it's just
it's like you know you put as a frog in
a boiling pot of water but you put them
in or it's like lukewarm and you slow
really cruel analogy into a mainstream
lexicon like ah like a frog in boiling
water geez who are you Glenn Close with
the pet rabbit and fatal interaction
can't you find something else I talk
about a room getting a little bit toasty
for adding steam to the rocks in the
sauna you're talking about boiling a pet
yeah anyway well that's that's what's
happened here it starts with social
distancing today but by the way don't
wear masks we've been saying on the show
slow erosion
if mats protect someone else maybe you
should wear some masks I certainly think
that masks are better in public than
eliminating all commerce but it started
with social distancing okay fine then it
started with stay at home people said
okay if we can do that fine then they
said don't actually don't support any of
these businesses stay home entirely okay
and then they started walking down
businesses
like in Michigan where now you can't buy
tires and carpet flooring at Lantz car
seats and people said okay then they
started arresting people on buses and in
public parks I think that if you were
just to look right now snapshot take
today go back a month and a half go back
to February we were still an impeachment
people would say oh my god what that's
gonna be America in a month and a half
you're gonna be dragging a black man off
of a bus because he's not wearing a
surgical mask which you said only two
weeks earlier wouldn't work anyway yeah
well now I've been it's been just
they're their defenses their liberty
defenses have been gradually weakened
right there we go
oh yeah the other there Billy the beat
cop is billy club in the a for the
person of color and tearing him off the
695 bus yeah you tried to get on the bus
to get a mask what are you gonna do well
I hope we learn a lesson from this
because the comparison of World War two
and World War two we were putting our
lives on the line to protect Liberty not
only for us but for the rest of the
world right and in this case we freely
gave that Liberty up to panic and fear
yeah right there are cases where we need
to come together and do extreme things
to mitigate risin risin cases when you
said come together come together okay
yeah but oh man yeah I am NOT the
Wohlers and that that necessarily
clarified we were all wondering please
don't die I won't tell you no but we we
need to make these kinds of you should
hear him do his rendition of I've got no
babes in proportion to the threat and
that's the only thing that we're asking
for we're not saying it's a hoax neither
Donald Trump we're not saying that this
isn't real we're not saying that open up
opening up the economy doesn't have it's
between risks right what we're saying is
we're trying to balance that more than
tooth I'll go further because I haven't
have a brass pair I think it's an
acceptable risk at this point oh I
absolutely at this well yeah absolutely
all our side keeping the clothes right
we all heard I did not we are
are you gonna put like the dub it over
me it's kept it close no I didn't say I
want it open because look we we take a
risk every single day here we gonna I
think this is no different with proper
precaution I don't know they haven't
started this this is just like throwing
the doctors and you're in the main
waiting room and they take you into a
smaller waiting sign say like attention
and then like fake news media like
there's little jabs at all the fake news
I wouldn't be surprised if attention Jim
Acosta
your wife's home alone I hope I don't
make a call because she'd rather go out
with me than you because I'm a real man
but I would never do that because I'm a
faithful husband but your wife would
take the author it's it would be huff to
fit that header it would I would all we
can see it's like fake news media this
way yeah yeah I wouldn't I could see
Donald Trump is a kind of guy who if you
were a fighter would like take the trash
talk to a whole other level
oh my Oh see that Trump Biden fight
right right you know let me don't hang
like I'm so bad I make medicine sick and
Donald Trump be like you know what I
bend your ways I hear you grandma has
cancer it's a great comparison when
people do that we tend to love them
right when they're just like when they
talk trash to people like and Donald
Trump does it and he's like oh he's just
a prick just a Jacke can't believe he
would say stuff like that now is that is
this just scale or is that middle guy on
a booster seat he's just he's that the
reporter is it being played by Peter
Boyle and I know he'd passed away so
it's in poor taste but it's not us it's
not a stab at Peter but I'm a boil fan
are you I was just saying he's talk why
would you try and pass on that I'm not
I'm asking a question
goo-goo-goo I'm just asking questions
Stephen yeah that's like Jesse Ventura
why is the fluoride in your jab oh it's
actually because of tooth decay he wants
you to believe go back your People
magazine and
talking about the Kardashians asses I'll
talk about the real facts that matter
what factor those questions
[Music]
okay riffraff this is amazing they
haven't started their 45-minute power
move it is a power yeah it's like you
will be no screens I notice I guess they
don't have a video prepped for us to
watch guys listen today I'm showing like
nice okay I'm not here to rub it in your
face isn't they just plays field of
dreams violin guys we're gonna play the
drinking game we are not going to be
carrying this so much because we want to
hear what they have to say and we want
you to actually be able to watch this
and we're doing the job that brian
Stelter refuses to do because who wants
to watch the briefing and matter a fat
closeted homosexual talk about it
instead drinking Rosalyn it what is he
drinking rules every time Trump says
China or of course any time that he says
testing China you ready or drink twice
if he destroys a reporter how long do
you wait to come out like how are you
sitting back there like I hold on 30
seconds yeah it looks like a lady in a
wedding dress is about to walk yeah
exactly like the Gracie train coming
y'all ready for this
there we go that's us there he is thank
you very much everyone I didn't know you
were here
clap start by saying that love and
prayers of every American continue to be
with our fellow citizens who have lost
the cherished friend or a family member
to the virus amidst our grief we're
making tremendous strides against this
invisible enemy thanks to our aggressive
campaign against the virus and the
extraordinary talent of our medical
professionals so hard from your knot
mentality rates remains roughly here
right oh yeah so many other countries
and one of the lowest migrant country in
the world I do nothing back to medical
professionals have been incredible since
we announced our guidelines on opening
up America as we call it
see opening up America and we had the
word of guns I think we can add the word
probably again we can do that in every
racist they are making plans and
preparations that was his punch up in
the very near future so that's 20 states
it's about 40% of our country they're
moving along pretty quickly three
announced today as you know and they're
going to be doing it safely they are
going to be doing it with tremendous
passion there's they want to get back to
work the country wants to get back to
work
there's your time ago the Senate passed
the paycheck protection program and
health care Enhancement Act with
additional funding for the Paycheck
protection program hospitals and testing
a lot of money for all of them
especially for our workers and our small
businesses my administration has worked
aggressively with Congress to negotiate
this critical 482 billion dollar funding
package we reached a deal that includes
three hundred and eighty two billion
dollar
and crucial small business support to
keep workers on the payroll seventy-five
billion dollars to aid hospitals which
really robber beneath the eight and very
badly very proud of that and twenty five
billion dollars to support this is the
most testing efforts I urge the house to
pass the bill and they're gonna be
voting on it I imagine very very soon
the only thing where he managed maybe
just get running back so I thought would
do about that now and they take a couple
of questions on that and then he can go
and start phase four probably they'll be
voting tomorrow the house but shortly
shortly and I think we have tremendous
support that's one two three four so
Steve those come up savory words yeah
thank you mr. president and thank you
for all your work with us to get this
passed I'd especially like to thank
Mitch McConnell and Chuck Schumer and
the entire Senate like they're passing
us makeup I'd also like to thank Ken the
clock as well and our chief of staff
mark meadows who was also very
instrumental in this let me just comment
we've had tremendous support for the PPP
this gives us another three hundred and
ten billion dollars for the PPP we look
forward to the house passing this
tomorrow and being up and running
quickly after that this also gives us
fifty billion dollars for disaster loans
eidelons that will allow the SBA to make
three hundred billion dollars of
disaster loans all for small businesses
also allows us as the president said
more money to hospitals and
unprecedented amount of money for
testing now and again I think we
understand because they offer loans
where they make their money let me make
just one more comment on the program we
have over a million companies that have
received this with less than ten where
so there is very broad participation and
in really small business I will comment
there have been some big businesses that
have taken these loans I was pleased to
see that Shake Shack returned to the
money we will be putting out some f8
cues there is a certification that
people are making and I ask people just
make sure the intent of this was for
business that needed the money we'll put
out an FAQ but again the intent of this
money was not for big public companies
that have access to capital so mr.
secretary are you gonna request that
those other companies obviously Shake
Shack was not alone in being a big
company that fit that they've got money
in this ruin it and they shouldn't be
taking it so Harvard's going to good you
have a number of I'm not gonna mention
any other names but when I saw Harvard
they have made one of the largest
endowments anywhere is one of them eight
the country maybe in the world I guess
and they're gonna pay back that money I
just want to clarify it because certain
people on the PPP may have not been
clear and understanding the
certification so we will give people the
benefit of the doubt we're gonna put in
FAQ out explain the certification if you
pay back the loan right away you won't
have liability to the SBA and to
Treasury but there are severe
consequences for people who don't test
properly this certification and again we
want to make sure this money is
available to small businesses that need
it people who have invested their entire
life savings
we appreciate what's going on and in
their hiring people back how are you
gonna ensure that those small businesses
those small restaurants and cafes bars
who did not get the money last time
around are gonna get at this time well
as I say boy and get it that are very
small working with the banks were
extremely pleased that the small banks
did great twenty percent of the loans
were made by banks of a billion unless
60 percent by by twenty billion in less
and the the big banks also we want
everybody to participate there's no a
lot of money back in the program
and we look forward to all these small
businesses getting access to fund bread
it's great to see you here thank you for
secretary did you know estimate how long
this is going to take that other pot of
money obviously went quickly Jews assume
this is going to go quickly as well well
let me just say I mean you know kind of
we're pleased with the success of this
program and how quickly this got up
operationally we've we want to thank all
the banks that have worked really hard
you make me weaken the means for more
money and this is gonna you know we've
already impacted about 30 million
workers they'll be they'll be a lot more
so we look forward to this having a big
impact on the economy
yes sir the president said you look into
the issue of felons those criminal
convictions I gave you access to some of
this this program update we worked with
the White House on this there were a
huge more onerous restrictions in the
SBA program there were people who had
misdemeanors that that weren't allowed
to access the program it was much longer
than five years and you know we very
much because of the criminal reform
legislation that was passed in the work
that's been done in the White House by
Jared and others we specifically
designed them I love by the way I can
talk about five years I love or that
well let me know if it were Bobby I love
that he said in treated with
misdemeanors where you're talking about
statute I think how he's saying of
course criminals shouldn't apply or
shouldn't be eligible and Joaquin
Phoenix wants them all right no we all
understand the circumstances and why
businesses need this but how many more
phases can we afford to have or can
businesses expect to have a do see up
phase five a phase six of eight seven
what's your thinking on this well first
of all I very much appreciate the
president's support for phase four he
put out a tweet I did do that
yeah the Gateway roads bridges broadband
especially broadband now to rural
America's is very important we've talked
about incentives for restaurants sports
entertainment because these businesses
have been impacted the president has
talked in multiple times but overall tax
cut and we've also we're talking about
in the lesson a capacity to thinkers
from the governor's so pay the same
square footage but don't make as much
right yeah what else do they fill their
coffers with whitner's wit mirrors just
real quick to follow up and the PPP
program is this the last tranche of
money you think you're gonna need your
small businesses 300 billion of logs
that's over six hundred billion dollars
and it's going toward the big banks and
going to small businesses but I do think
if you look now at the numbers that we
see for this virus we need it now
because of all the measures have been
taken but it it didn't need to go this
far I know it's an unpopular opinion so
sue me I think we should have taken
precautions I think we should be safe I
don't think we should need effectively
what are we at most I'm talking about
truly a close kids oh please have six
hundred billion we could bring that up
you guys can bring it up as an overlay
the total I don't have a number in front
overseas away their deficit 600 billion
in petroleum worth more than the more
evidence you should just open up the
economy let's let things go back to
normal
for full transparency we have no
obligation to put up full transparency
on money that had been sent out on the
PPP mr. dates
showing all the big lenders how it was
distributed no one lender did more than
4% showed the businesses so again the
president I very much believe in full
transparency we're spending a lot of
money and we want to make sure that it's
done effectively and fairly thank you
you started by thanking the leaders in
the House and the Senate can you tell us
more about how it's not easy Harry I
want you guys to actually see this dream
because I know you can't access working
around the clock maybe it's been very
good bipartisan support to get this done
the the Congress is coming together
understanding the importance of this and
we've been working around the clock for
days so this is important legislation it
was a lot we spoke to a lot of people
mark Meadows has been fantastic as I
said it's great to have him here in the
White House I couldn't have done this
without him working on this with me and
the president and vice president have
been available to us around the clock so
this was a big team effort collaboration
of the Democrats
absolutely we couldn't have done this
today without unanimous consent and the
Democrats being on board and we look
forward to jerec just being down
expectations a real example of the
country coming together about you
again I think we're not we're not at the
point of designs Joker killed on a
subway especially what's going on today
but the president has talked about you
know I was on the campaign with the
president we've been talking about
bridges and tunnels and rebuilding this
country for years so the president wants
to make a big investment in this this
Mitch McConnell we see the 17 billion
dollars my fortune of care is reserved
for companies critical for national
security and also will all companies fit
into that at all per the president's
Putin's smaller yes so we're in the
process of putting out by the way Nile
was starting along really is not
directly a national disaster baited by
it is their problem with food I think
it's criminal the way they don't go into
a net negative you have to pay people to
expose the poor so not only is oil worth
nothing or then it's actually a net cost
because so June and July are much higher
and we look forward to both looking at
what existing capabilities we have and
that will be something we may need to go
back to Congress and get additional
funding similar to that you're playing
with your lying bailout situation I mean
what you have the Airlines is someone
make Delta destroy a very good again
virus virus demands a partially also
because of too much supply but you know
the president is determined we want to
make our fans are traveling options and
what we're doing that obviously pretty
extraordinary can't afford a so the
front no it's true like all the us
season that when I started they put
people on Spirit
stimulus bill and aid to state and local
government
any thoughts on whether that money
should be proportionate to have the rate
of infection and state so that the
question basically sits however we do
want to bipartisan basis
the president has listened to the
governor's I've had the opportunity on
multiple video conference calls with the
president and vice president reaching
out to a lot of people there's a lot of
states lots of impacted but I got to be
the big one large company applies for
one of these loans and they manipulates
or works a system or work some loopholes
to get it what are some that
consequences to you know if a large
company loans what can you do shouldn't
be late I'm gonna give people the
benefit of the doubt again we're gonna
put up very clear guidance it's gonna be
really hard to catch people doing that
so that people understand what the
certification is what it means if you're
a big company the nature having again
there is a you know where there are
multiple affiliate domestic inequity but
the integrant was not for companies that
have access to plenty of liquidity and
other sources
everybody get stories from friends
pretty sure about potentially other
consequences can you talk about what
those consequences again you can look at
the certifications they're they're quite
significant how many jobs have been
saved with all the money that's going on
billions so far well I can't tell you
the PPP so far is over 30 million jobs
and again that doesn't account for other
money that you have sent out and again
we're very pleased the direct deposits
how good it out we've started some
president fossa do you see that he's
glad you did that capability so we can
get money out quickly to people
everything that the president has had us
working on is providing significant you
tell me that isn't Gary economy while
we're dealing with this difficult time
what their small business qualified
pimp was forced to give it back to the
Fed after back handing a prostitute that
was a nice question actually it's good
questions
oh so the noble fight against the
invisible enemy is inflicted a steep
toll on the American workforce as we all
know millions of Americans sacrificed
their jobs in order to battle the virus
and save the lives of their fellow
citizens we have a solemn duty to ensure
these unemployed Americans regain their
jobs and their livelihoods therefore in
order to protect American workers clear
about this I will be issuing a job
suspension early immigration into they
are not heroes last night
tribute to say the economy recovery
Alice was inflicted upon them by the
virus to be replaced with new immigrant
labor flown in immigrant Mubarak really
there was much first take care of
Philbert the American worker take care
of the American spilled beer and it went
in my chest hole this pores will be in
effect for 60 days 108 for any extension
or modification will be evaluated by
myself and folks droplets a group of
people based on economic conditions at
the time disorder will only apply to
individuals seeking a permanent
residency in other words those receiving
green cards big factor will not apply to
those entering on a temporary basis as
we move forward we'll examine what
additional immigration related maybe it
would be is why they don't like the
press briefings Japan he's stopping all
immigrant workers and he also just said
no no it's only houses were trying to
forward trying to relocate permanently
so it's better for them than it is to
let him explain so they can frame well
either way CNN it's losing you're
playing with a donation they're going to
depending on the time we're talking
about will protect the solvency of our
health care system and provide relief to
jobless Americans today vice president
pants visited the hard-working men and
women of General Electric healthcare in
Madison Wisconsin who are working three
shifts a day to quadruple their
production of ventilators were way ahead
of schedule on ventilators as you know
that's why it's never brought up by the
media they don't like to bring things
right ge is also working with Ford to
make 50,000 ventilators in the next 100
days more than our entire country
typically produces in a very long period
of time doing that in a few weeks and a
few days you could even count in hours
discuss doubling testing in the next few
weeks
testing drink works data will be
continuing to control the testing of
their citizens drink were also managed
as stated in local laboratories they
have a lot of great laboratories there
more than anybody would ever have known
frankly the federal government will I
[Laughter]
stand corrected
[Laughter]
you I can say very honestly with New
York State in New York City they've been
terrific to work with the New York
metropolitan area has been the epicenter
of the outbreak here in America and the
federal government has spared no expense
or a resource to get New Yorkers the
care they need in the care they deserve
we've sent over 5 million masks we had
five million masks and now that number
as of
[Laughter]
95 certified but it is large was set as
you know to New York and it was
originally for more of a normal this is
good new medical purposes in Cuomo
you've been praising people that
operative relationship that's why they
don't run probably that's why we're
doing we know so well unfortunately that
we know so well I said from the
beginning that no American who needs a
ventilator would be denied a ventilator
and we have kept that promise all over
the United States think of that of the
countries that is a federal a that is
accurate by the way we've had many
deaths because remember ventilators will
be done and bring the comfort back
that's why they don't run these reboots
base in Virginia so that we can have it
for other locations and he said we would
be able to do that Javits Center has
been a great help to them but we'll be
bringing the ship back at the earliest
time and we'll get it ready for its next
mission which will I'm sure would be a
very important one also but it was it
was an honor they they reconverted it
after I got there into handling an event
that they were not expecting to be
handling the FDA is now authorized more
than 50 diagnostic tests including as of
late last night the first taste test
that a patient can take home you can
take it at home and it's a highly
accurate
LabCorp intends to make the Home
Collection kits available to consumers
in most states with a doctor's order in
the coming weeks we also afford
different antibody tests already
authorized tests will help identify
individuals who can donate convalescent
Klauss provide intentionally life-saving
antibodies to the new element patients
dr. Han will be providing you with an
update on these developments in a few
moments he's done a great job at the FDA
we continue to gain ground in the war
against the unseen enemy and I see light
at the end of the tunnel I really see a
lot of light at the end of the day that
lib starting the process was you see by
the life anxious they want to get rolled
up and get back to their job like a
deuce but I would never touch it so the
light is getting brighter and brighter
every day and with that if I could I'll
ask dr. Burks to come up and then dr.
Han thank you very much speak scarf
scarf it's challenging on her no you
know that we've been talking about the
New York metro area she's very fetching
lady she puts herself together very well
she's pretty she I don't know there's
something about it well with significant
declines now okay Orleans is nearly back
to their baseline of where they started
we also are seeing improvements in
Chicago and Boston and that has been a
great concern was helpful and that's
really tough to do and Houston Atlanta
Nashville Baltimore Indianapolis and st.
Louis also appear to be flattening the
DC metro area we don't see a decline yet
so I'm hopefully all of you are still
social distancing and doing everything
that you can I wanted to remind
everybody of two points when we brought
up and the president put out the
guidelines for opening up America
again it was very clear to use data and
to really work together to mitigate
against any resurgence and also
critically to protect the vulnerable and
what we're seeing across rural American
and some of the smaller pop population
states is we're still seeing outbreaks
in long-term care facilities and we
asked everyone in phase one to make sure
that they continued their social
distancing and public to ensure that the
vulnerable with comorbidities and other
conditions and then what they mean by
that is nursing keep in mind that
actually the highest nursing it's high
school and they're so because they get
around they do they get frequent they do
get a review before they had their
system it's not it's not out of the
realm of plausibility that they would
also no really want to call people's
attention again to the guidelines we are
continuing to see outbreaks dose nursing
homes and in confined spaces and I think
as Americans we want to stop that and we
have the ability to do that by really
paying attention to the guidelines that
were to be in all three phases and so
I'm calling on the states again to note
that they form community about the three
phases on CNN or ABC CBS not very often
you hear he just wants to open the doors
why just wide open right now to the
economy as if he hasn't a plan yes if
there's no plan that's why they don't
air these briefings that's why we have
to I don't want to be doing this I mean
we love you find Maddox before as an
early one of the viewers oh yes well no
among indigenous populations and of
course in our long-term care facilities
in prisons we really want to support
state and local governments to move
forward on these critical monitoring to
protect individuals that may be in the
most critically vulnerable States we
will continue to fund mortality and
deaths among our American citizens
particularly in the cities as they begin
to move past peak because deaths will
lag and so we really need to continue to
unite and we really really really
support our health care providers who
check her out
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I just want to echo what dr. Burke's
been skeletor just a wonderful work that
they that they do every day so President
Trump asked the FDA to remove all
unnecessary barriers that were in place
to help with the development of both
diagnostics and therapeutics and we have
done that they're unnecessary why
because I read an article which I know
or into bio tests which detect in the
blood the nominees talking about that
someone might spell it in response to in
fact maybe never top 19
these aren't diagnostic tests but these
are tests that actually detect the
antibody so an indication that one has
very more effective and has responded
and I think it's important for everyone
to understand that the timing of the
response of the antibody to the
infection isn't completely known but we
know that it takes some time to actually
develop that and there's two types of
antibody responses that can be detect
and the antibody tests are just one
piece of the larger response that you've
heard in the America returning to work a
plan that the president has with the
task force has developed and this
pandemic is truly unprecedented in
nature and you'll see reports around the
world of different antibody tests that
have been used and I think that's a
reflection of the fact that we're just
learning to and beginning to understand
what that response looks like and many
of these tests have different
characteristics that allow to detect at
different points in the infection I do
want to address one issue that we are
laser focused on at FDA and that is in
an effort to provide laboratories and
health care providers the early access
to tests we issued a policy earlier in
March that allowed test developers the
opportunity to quickly get their tests
to market and address the needs of the
nation as posed by the epidemic in March
we provided this regulatory flexibility
to manufacturers and here's what we
required of them the manufacturers had
to validate their tests we call it self
validation similar to what many test
developers in the world have done they
had to notify FDA that they had
performed that validation and then they
had to label their products
appropriately in the package in certain
with information about the validation as
well as the fact that it's not a
diagnostic test that it's an antibody
test and the bottom line here is that
FDA still expects manufacturers and test
developers to validate their antibody
tests even under this revised policy now
we've done a couple of things to
actually help end users to help
laboratories providers etc States in
terms of their use of these antibody
tests one is that we're working with CDC
and NCI to actually Valerie was getting
more than 90 and that process is going
grow body more information especially
that of miss Berg
the doctor by the FD but actually hasn't
we've authorized applications of course
as we speak so it's not okay for someone
to say that a testaments authorized or
approved by FDA when it hasn't and we
are pursuing them both by in direct
contact with the manufacturers but also
at the border and so we have increased
these interdiction efforts and we will
continue to outreach and do and do that
start some really crappy antibody
testing the Tran flee yeah we will beat
you at the border that's a good gag like
someone who hopped over from an e/m way
quick let's hightail it to Tijuana know
that much developers more than 90
manufacturers how many of these tests
actually work so as I mentioned the 911
from China said they're marketing the US
they are required by us to have self
validation and they're required to label
that appropriately in their package
insert they also said that we're what
we're doing just working with folks
around the country I wasn't listening
because here's what happens right now
they want a quicker response so they can
blame Donald Trump then if the tests
aren't 100% foolproof they'll blame him
for rushing it out because Donald Trump
was inventing the test he was attached
to had a big spin around the country
that have done that we've actually
reached out to the many academics and we
will be including that information in
the information that we generate as well
to provide
Pietro da today on hydroxychloroquine
that found the higher mortality rate
compared to those in that standard of
care this is a large-scale clinical
drive but since this is like us out
there and people are you - we're already
can you read some takeaways from that
study did that change your thinking at
all no so this study is a small
retrospective study at the VA and and
similar to the data we talked about
before with the French study this is
something that a doctor would need to
consider as part of a decision in
writing prescription pride Roxie
chloroquine and as I've mentioned from
this podium in and other venues before
with what FDA is going to require is
data from clinical trials randomized
clinical trials hydroxychloroquine
placebo to actually make a definitive
decision around safety and efficacy but
the preliminary data are helpful to
providers and doctors I want to ask them
to incorporate the data as we have it
come forward and it's not definitive
data it doesn't help us make a decision
from a regulatory point of view but
doctors should incorporate that in the
decision-making they make on a
one-on-one basis so the good news is we
have over 30 clinics now the settings
are very different there in the
outpatient setting there in the
inpatient setting and also I think very
importantly in what we call the post
exposure really appreciating the
industries if you're a healthcare
without our frontline provider and
you've been exposed to the virus take
the drug for a period of time to see if
you can prevent the development of
illness related to the virus
so all those trials are in progress and
will probably be early summer before we
get a readout
in addition FS that we already have and
we have tested more people than anybody
anywhere in the world by far by very far
well I think you want to file of Omaha
drug succeed in our Quinn I wonder if
you're concerned this this VA study
showed that actually more people died
they use the drug look and if you're not
controlling our condition Governor Cuomo
and they're really really bad to you
let's give them the that's why it's
different work some of these thirty
others of trials and such and perhaps
this one it's not a good report but
we'll be looking at it we'll have a
comment on a panel of experts at the NIH
is actually now recommending against the
use of hydroxychloroquine in combination
with z-pak which is something you okay
recommended I'm always willing to take a
look Brett other subject you were at the
same man exactly what about all the
other ones the executive order will be
it's being written now as we speak
probably tomorrow sometimes will it have
exemptions in there will have certain
exemptions cuz you're gonna need certain
exceptions but we'll be notifying you
tomorrow we'll sign it
wait drink by the way that was on the
information by the way Johnny boy people
who said it doesn't attract with opening
up the country of Kingdom also be shut
down in the bridge one obstacle for
companies that and the pipeline that's
already in place what do you say well I
think it really does I think it's very
strong obviously and it's countrywide as
opposed to specifically like China or
you hit the dank lesson for me North
Korea what do you what can you tell us
about the status Kim jong-il reports it
came that makes me a little nervous man
if he dies because of our relationship
with China and what we sort of need as
far as international relations to
mitigate the damage and people to this
is why the executive order is also
probably pretty important because gonna
be looking at a bunch of people trying
to flee North Korea reports it
introduces say there'll be a that's a
very serious condition as you know but I
wish him well he needs one too we've had
a good relationship I've said it and
I've said it many times if somebody else
were in this position we would have been
right now at war with North Korea and
we're not at war we're nowhere close to
war with North Korea so I just have to
say to Kim Jimin I wish it were I know
as long as trying to help her good luck
I mean they came out with very very
serious medical reports nobody's
confirmed that it's C and then that came
out so when CNN comes out with the
report I don't place too much credence
in it thank you of a need for expanded
testing or contest emergency doctor is
going we have an agreement labs as you
know in New York especially is burned
Manhattan area but all over the state in
great great medical schools and federal
labs so we we have a very good
understanding we're gonna do a very
significant testing you know not
everybody wants to do such significant
testing testing is good in some cases
and some cases it's not you have
governors that don't want to go because
we're it by good for my child
but I must have died the governor
another governor's who want to that ban
testing because we keep hearing at all
we [ __ ] it's a penguin sorry I know you
know and again already we're testing
more by far than any country I think I
read yesterday a report that we've done
more than everybody else every other
country combined and I think our people
should be getting a lot of credit for
that we've done a lot more than
everybody else combined and you never
hear not a spirit of fairness we don't
have the most testing uses different
metrics to bring up the testing for
capital let me don't bring up the death
rate okay I think the per capita number
matters are certainly significantly
higher up between the testing per capita
might be tonight or tomorrow well give
you an executive you said people who may
be worried about giving people in free
family no I think it's been covered
pretty accurately in this case I think
most people know what it is and some
people will be able to get in we have to
do that by the way I want to be really
clear that chloroquine study this is
from the AP there's a study of 65 year
old or older veterans with an average of
three underlying condition three that
the median not the mean the average not
supposed to be here you're saying
they're here illegally is that what you
say well for example if an immigrant is
here for a court order right and then
you have to go to court so then the
judge would make a determination as to
whether or not they're going to be
staying but if they have a court order
they won't have to leave until they go
through that process so we'll see what
happens but with the court and there are
some with court orders that means they
have a trial coming up please so
obviously on the immigration executive
order you raise concern for a long time
even in good economic
about immigrants taking Americans jobs
so under what conditions would you
consider lifting this halt on
immigration yeah sort of an opportunity
to address what you've seen as a problem
for a long time well I think look right
now obviously there's never been where
the greatest economy in the world and
then one day we had to shut it down they
said you have to shut it down we did the
right thing because I think we would
have had a million or maybe even two
million it may be more than that death
so we did the right thing but just to
say this would pertain I mean when you
look at it just using the last thing we
want to do is take American workers jobs
it's one thing when we were essentially
they used to call it full employment and
it's another thing right now right now
we have people that have lost their jobs
and we hope they're gonna come back and
get really good way to put it we can
have we have job participation 5% what
we love to see I mean I hope we're in
that position to have that debate right
now we're not in that position right now
we closed down a the largest economy the
greatest economy in the history of the
world it's a little better than that
just kill the records it was a knack
every time she and Joe buy stock markets
still not doing badly considering what
this country has been through which way
tells you how strong it was in the first
place
but no I hope we're gonna be able to
have that discussion I hope we're in a
position that's like a good discussion
and it's happening it would be a little
later Brett for dr. Brooks about the CDC
director said in an interview that
perhaps this second wave of the chronic
virus in the fall could be worse because
it is timed with the seasonal flu very
clear in the guidelines that we believe
we can monitor again monitor communities
at the community level by using the
influenza like illness and the cinder
ohmic respiratory and gastrointestinal
components of this oh good this
particular I was hoping we would use
those come obviously when we have flu
we're going to and we're working on an
algorithm I don't have to test for just
going sure that we are building the
testing car city to be able to do that
because I think it's very important that
you're gonna be able I on the surface a
patient when they come in with early flu
and early kovat can look very she's
pretty know I think she could have
picked a scarf that wasn't we style of
Jurassic Park Jeep boy task we're also
hoping by that time that we have
addition kovat nineteen so that there
will be additional and to be fair that
the virus can mutate friendly direction
they can become less violent unless
that's absolutely true that's what's
what happened in nineteen eighteen is
okay listen I'm reading a book right now
I feel like no pictures at all it's very
important to completely and a
comprehensive a lot of popping into well
changes every time it goes through
enough of a population the virus will
mutate and change and sometimes it
becomes much more difficult for us to
deal with and sometimes it just runs its
course and becomes less deadly show
anyone who speaks French out there
there's no what that means if you're in
all these chat so you're gonna be this
clean come back a free cigar that your
hand works worse I think this has been
pretty bad when you see what I said
before that was very bad I believe that
we'll have early warning signals both
from our surveillance that we've been
talking on about in these Vuitton the
vulnerable populations we're going to
continue that surveillance from now all
the way through the fall to be able to
give us that early warning signal I
think what we've learned is how good
Americans are about immediately
reverting to all of those issues that
they need to do in order
to ensure that they're protected and
their families mr. president what do you
say this but concerns like Georgia is
opening up barber shops and bowling
alleys in the life and you saw it
Lindsey Graham is saying he's concerned
that Georgia may be going too far too
fast and it could affect people in South
Carolina obviously travel back we work
between states how do you protect
sanitizer Bob South Carolina for
examples based on the line between
intentionally bad decision by a governor
in Georgia so he's a very capable man he
knows what he's doing he's done a very
good job as governor Georgia and and by
the way in South Carolina Governor
McMaster also so you have two very
capable people we're going to find out
and in fact I'm scheduled to speak to
the governor of Georgia in a little
while but we'll we'll find it Graham's
concern that what happens in Georgia I
have a concern about what happens
everywhere I mean we've got those
concerns not just Georgia come back
together with heavier happening I'm
concerned about we have because I'm
already able to put 49 other states and
I think about them what's happening when
you look at the numbers coming down a
lot of states are in really great shape
and see a lot of openings but I'll be
speaking to the governor of Georgia in a
little while yeah so the American people
need to be prepared for going back to
social distancing even if things about
blacks over the summers it over the
summer come fall if the man is coming
back in committee to see them and I'll
speak for the doctor and if you like
either of you to say but I would say did
you keep away or until this thing is gun
it's gonna be gone at some point it's
gonna be gun gun and I would say watch
they're gonna take that quote no
executive order first this will be far
from gone gun
I'm gonna go crawl back into my Casper
and eat a pint of bitter I hope that the
economy is gonna be great by that time
but we'll see but right now in light of
the fact that Americans are out of jobs
I can't be have I can't be taken in for
another 60 days well I could or I could
roll it for 30 days or I could roll it
for much more than 60 days we have to
take a look at the time but we'll be
looking at 60 days and we'll see what it
works drink
immigration home go why don't you go and
then you the only Gration order we'll
continue with that there is reporting
that you may actually sign a second
order to we're just talking about if I
want but I won't be doing it tomorrow
I'll be signing the primary order and
then we have a secondary order that if I
want to do that will make that
determination we can do that yeah we
could do that at a little bit different
time if we walk that is under
consideration at the secondary orders
yeah please
Thank You mr. president I have two
questions reporter could not tell yes
there will be some highlights that will
be taken where he's gotten testy and
that's what's the medium that's what the
run that's why they don't want you to
watch the original immigration order you
campaigned on reducing legal immigration
remember Metasploit TV in officience
2016 on reducing legal immigration and
illegal but no I've always said you have
to come into the country legally drink
all three drinks now that's what I
campaigned on was people just flooding
our border and stopping and by the way
speaking of that we have a hundred and
seventy miles almost 170 miles of a very
powerful border wall up and it's moving
rapidly very quickly and it's having a
tremendous business
wall in history and it's making our job
a lot easier plus Mexico has 27,000
soldiers right now on our southern
border that we share with them and
Mexico has been terrific they've really
helped you also campaigned on reducing
legal and liberation
I'm wondering if some critics are saying
that you are using the virus now in this
crisis to follow through on that promise
to reduce illegal well I want people
that are in this country I want our
citizens to get jobs I don't want them
to have competition we have a very
unusual situation where something came
in that nobody has seen for many many
decades probably nineteen seventeen
would be the closest analogy if you look
at it when you look at the contagion the
kind of contagion we're talking about so
no I'm not I'm not doing that at all I
want I want the American worker and the
American our American citizens to be
able to get jobs I don't want them to
compete right now there's a big
difference when we have a full economy
and frankly where some of the companies
we have many companies moving in where
they need actually they need workers
that's a big difference between that and
where all of a sudden a lot of people
lose jobs actually no a lot of farmers
rely on seasonal migrant workers
expected migrant farmers yeah that's an
important point
drinking angles up really quick
important point I mean it's a great
point actually I'm I'm glad you brought
it up sir any kind of everybody from
coming on the Stephen list drink great
craft beer without me it's easy it's
easy to stop everything cold put your
name softer than it is to plant it so
that the farmers have the people that
have been working in those farms for
many years and and that's what we're
doing no the farmers will not be
affected by this at all if anything
we're gonna make it easier and we're
doing a process that'll make it better
for those workers to come in to go to
the farm where they've been for a long
time for questions for reporters out of
the room is for The Washington Times Tom
Howell why hasn't the CDC the federal
government's main disease by I find it
to be the only guy in there
endemic in something regular media calls
and it's gonna clamor around his neck a
border decision that I made last night
and the directors the directors own a
few masks we have Tony or Deborah or one
Steve I have always a lot of people up
and certainly had you seen the directors
been here a lot right he's been here has
been sitting here has been speaking a
lot no no CDC is very much involved and
everything we've done you've encouraged
some of these protests 5sec director
saying these people want to get back to
work and I've watched some of the
protests not in great detail but I see
that and they're separated they're a lot
of space in between I mean they they're
watching believing this is where it all
Trump they're doing social distancing if
you can believe it instead of an ice
road testing but instead of belittling
them you say I understand that these
people want to spread out so I think
that's good look yeah he looks really
good I want to get back to work they got
to make a living they have to take care
of their family they don't want to do
this it's a you know unfortunate maybe
one way or the other both are
unfortunate both are unfortunate but you
have a lot of people out there that are
anxious to get back yep certainly seem
to be indicating the people are actually
more concerned more people are concerned
about the virus spread they don't want
to go out there to grits to feed their
both the big groups both of them we have
to build back our country and I'm gonna
make our country's big difference
because people have really been
and they'd stand before nobody had ever
heard anything to say I mean nobody ever
heard of a thing like this distancing
social distancing what does that mean
washing hands every 15 minutes what does
that mean more fun than anybody else
whatever you want but the governor's I
want them to do it if they if we see
them doing something we don't like we'll
stop it very quickly but they're doing a
good job they're being careful some of
the governor's frankly they're in a
position where they could do it sooner
they are doing a little bit later and
that's okay but who's gonna go under
governor Gavin money break over this we
can't do it just we have my own
unpopular that might run for governor
here so long as you can do it nail salon
does he hilarious tattoo partners dr.
Burks can you weigh in on this because
the people of Atlanta was here from you
that's supposed to chuck me I know the
rules except safely have hair salons and
nail salons and tattoo parlors where
people really should be forced to ask
those parts to inherently be close to
get information to their communities and
show very clearly the data we remember
we wanted this data and evidence-based
the data that they utilize to make
decisions and the data that the mayor
should use in each of the communities
because it will have to be on a
community by community opening because
there are different a new sure manatees
and DeLuise all girls even in Georgia
and so I believe people in Atlanta what
under
that if they're cute was not going down
I don't know that they need to continue
to do everything that we said these
other children's series your assignments
wearing a mask in public so if there's a
way that people can Harper wears the
mask in the pager fine I think then they
can do those things I don't know how but
people are very creative so I'm not
gonna prejudge people very nearly in the
president guidelines misused a [ __ ] you
should post it to your elbow here let me
show you from behind that scar for
creepy Joe Biden your turn to pottery
from ghost
yeah it's up to the governors and
mayor's to ensure that they're following
the best they can each of those phases
to make sure that both of the public is
completely protected but the governors
and mayor's also need to communicate
very clearly on the data that was used
for decision-making and make that
transparent and available to the reason
because this is entirely data-driven and
there are there's a litany of experts
who are being involved in the analysis
and they want you to think that he's
some rogue age right now they get a
sense of what you have left my toolbox
as it relates to the way you hashed out
to deal with hope that busts you watered
for purchases into the SPR I mean what
else can be the biggest thing opened the
economy is to get our country open thank
you yeah by far the biggest the only
thing you have to do if we can open the
way if you don't get the economy all
pretty well who do you think is going to
generate tests that's pandemic right in
a price puzzle you don't tend to use
with you old well when it's staying
about your biggest part right as much as
you would otherwise that's where the
engine is more than any other things
always of course remain open with wider
to New York related questions in your
meeting with Governor Cuomo was there
talk about providing states like New
York with aid
fourth stimulus package wondering if you
have any thoughts on whether that aid
should be tied to infection rates
whether states like New York New Jersey
that have been hardest hit should
receive my ticker tape Korean exports
once this is all over to honor the
health care workers frankly that sounds
like a good idea to me when it's all
over it sounds like a great idea they
deserve it their Warriors have done an
incredible job we mentioned briefly the
state aid we talked about that Governor
Cuomo myself and I agree with him on
that and I think most Republicans agree
- and Democrats and that's part of phase
four and I think infrastructure is going
to be a big part we have to rebuild our
country I mean you take a look where we
spent and we go over this all the time
with eight trillion dollars in the
Middle East we want to rebuild our
country that means our bridges or
tunnels even schools we're doing
something with schools we have to do all
roadways that what's happened we spent
so much money on other countries that
don't even that they don't appreciate it
that's right okay they don't appreciate
it we're gonna spend money now on our
country we're gonna be Syria it took our
questioner pads it's gonna be made much
of it is gonna be made here hopefully at
some point all of its gonna be red here
Joe is president yeah what about the New
York subway in between drill guys off of
public transit to beat them with billy
clubs because they don't wear a mask
forget to feed your dishes as you know
now six weeks later we still saw the
rest of Americans who need ever need
supplies or plants or carpet they go
without but the New York elite they get
to huddle up and imprint gel's cans
filled with human droplets and farts
very big essentially more than a cake
when here in the world we have one of
the most successful if you call
mortality finding any place in America's
America more contaminated than the
l-train correct one person is too many
all wait but we've done very well our
testing if you add them all up we've
tested more now I don't know
what Mike Pence said but I'm sure he
could answer that 4 million tests and
we're so later we're reading again we've
tested more than every country in the
world even put together so do you get
more like I said again there's Mike Hill
enter your question back to mama I just
want to go back to the China do you know
in the face one of the China drinks
white ban is still in place how big are
you that the Chinese are not going to
use the old folks natural design
applause Dave wait before getting into
that we're gonna sink
there's nobody ever be tougher on China
than me and that means for 20 years you
go bad drink that I've been very tough I
said John has been ripped or you're
talking more use that speech is
unrelated to being a politician I'd be
invited I'd be speaking to people and
his love which I like to do expense
related candy I love the staple of this
country which is skills I open s say how
did you let this happen with China I
even ask the leaders of China sure did
this ever happened doctor up stopper our
country loses tens of billions of
dollars you're not going and I don't
mean to you sneeze into 200 billion
through Johnny boy John and about 500
billion dollars I'm more to five or how
did they ever let anything like this
happen now if you look at this last year
the deficit went way down and I'm
talking about even before now it's much
different but a lot of things are
happening that's gonna weigh different
I'm talking away we should stop trying
to do the better
but if that happens we'll do a
termination and we'll do oh and I can do
told you that the virus escaped from a
Chinese research lab that was incredible
to pay the money back okay I don't like
it in schools in the world
mr. Trump and he travels everywhere with
a hammock so you can't have anything
open and you say what are we gonna do
have full payroll and have the whole
place with you no there's no income
coming in first of all everyone's home
and they're supposed to be
second of all Florida you can't use golf
courses that one area walking in a
partner's no easier way to sit there is
another sport where you can socially
distance like the golf
where you can stay hundreds of yards
away from another group
it's like saying we need to close the
biathlon tracks well they're closed
property is like you know you have to
close them up and then hopefully when
things get better we'll just open it up
but you can't have you know many
hundreds of employees standing around
doing nothing there's no customer you're
not allowed to have a customer and
that's the places it's very strict
they're not even allowed between Obama
stimulus initialism I'm generally
against federal intervention but when
interviewed by telling people don't
support their business so it was caused
by intervention its intervention as a
swing yeah I actually kind of accept
that there's responsibility accepted by
this government that hey listen we
screwed did it so we're gonna try and
make up for well this is why you don't
screw around earlier right you don't
empty the coffers on something you know
I need to for something like this thing
that's a good thing and I'd like to see
them be well and we'll see how he does
again I don't know that the reports not
to my attention as far as I know I don't
want to ask them that I have this and
that but it's not it's not it's not my
when you die purpose is coming at that
right after you need to bring back
Rodman comment when you die kim jong i
want your back said it was a masterpiece
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the world and with CDC - really - barb
some things that people could understand
some blood and used in the past yeah but
it was built on the premise that it
needs to be data-driven and it needs to
protect those who are most vulnerable
and then it went through the phases it
says in all individuals and Jacksonville
is dermat wonder if you rephrases things
in his head like comes up with a better
way of saying I'm not gonna second you
know judge anyone about their
decision-making what I'm gonna say is we
were very clear and what we really
believe protects the safety of Americans
and that is clearly laid up I laid out
in the opening up America again it's a
bad question because we got data from
Tokyo any recent cases and a double of
the cases insane
or what we've been you know looking a
lot at Europe after China and then we're
back into this area of the world here
we're not getting about the plateau and
then cases going down any less it's a no
questions for this week and what in this
area said we don't want that to happen
it could happen I think we stamp it out
if it does happen we're not gonna be
doing it in my video she was saying
should happen so I think we could you
know I called some Bernie embers and we
put them out and I think we've gotten
very good thing on top of that thing in
the fire cause I don't want that to
happen now absolutely because I mr.
president
what's the reopening happen we won't
need to go back into reclosing I don't
want to do that you don't want to do
this you know Ryan said you're right the
room seems so empty this way but it's
one of those things yeah go ahead please
and it says USA Today poll just came out
and found 80% of Americans are
supportive of the immigration at all the
temporary for yes any public support
have any effect on your decision-making
here and are you surprised I did not see
that number I heard there was a poll I'm
sure there'll be a lot of polls no look
I think the American people want to make
sure that they have jobs for the
American people not for people that come
in in many cases illegally into our
country so we're doing that I don't know
what the numbers are they don't want to
run the briefings I think just common
sense tells you that's where we should
go in this with illegal immigration
which should have been done before this
pandemic but now at this point is
unforgivable so they want to talk about
Donald Trump's executive order rather
than allow him to lay it out so we're
gonna have something that he really
needs those roads and bridges and
tunnels and highways and all of the
other things we're going to be building
and broadband for the Middle West I mean
the farmers haven't been treated for
building bridges across farmers have
been treated terribly when it comes to
the internet so we're going to take care
of that we're going to we're gonna make
them very happy so we'll see you all
tomorrow and the watch game interesting
things to put out tonight and I
appreciate it Gooper it's an honor to
have Britt bear here I've used his slot
a lot John use that slot a lot we want
to have you back thank you very much
thank you
peace on out rather cordial all right
well listen like I said we did our best
to not add anything but I just can't
help myself especially when you're a
reporter hunt a dead ringer for mr. bean
yeah so this is interesting watch it he
they talked about phase four yeah they
talked about because the three phase
sort of a reopening of the economy and
then they mentioned phase four and then
they asked him something about six
phases at some point on what that means
it was generally an honestly outside of
Bret Baier and that one American news
who by the way did you notice she wasn't
in one of those sort of Delta lounge bar
separate separately like put her in it
yeah they didn't give her but they
allowed her to come back three drinks
section it was really mostly pretty
cordial there were a few times where he
got testy now I guarantee you if you go
to HuffPo if you go to Reddit politics
go to CNN they're going to take the
interactions that were more hostile and
I would say rightfully so because you
think yeah if you have interactions
let's say with a roomful of people let
me ask you this if you go to a house
party okay and there are twenty thirty
people how much you want to bet at least
one of them is gonna be an [ __ ] but
should you be judged by how you played
catch phrase with the singular [ __ ]
know how you played it with the group he
did it it was overall a give-and-take um
I think he was pretty himself was pretty
descriptive dr. Brooks is great I think
she's actually way better than phone she
I think she's good to actually have it's
really talking about her by the way and
I think the reason for that is because
foul she has sometimes come come out and
sort of contradicted Donald Trump and
and again he's very narrow sighted in
his approach to this which is just the
medical side of issues dr. Brooks you
heard her talk about sort of the medical
she kind of data-driven that we do have
to make sure that testing is up to snuff
and that different states will have to
be taking different approaches but that
we also need to balance that with the
economy this was honestly I mean he
looked tired to me
he definitely a little less normal right
you know when you say punchy you mean a
little bit less a little less fire and
I'm not Punk like Jabba no no no not
punch truck he can complete center right
yeah that's no Joe Joe Biden you know
makes Larry Holmes
sound like a Mensa member well and love
that we're Garry Shandling yes so this
is remarkable to me I think that first
off this is if not during what you call
the worst crisis of our life the worst
crisis in several hundred years where
you have compared to World War two
what you have compared to all other
penned the pandemic to end all pandemics
if at that point in history by your own
description you don't run the briefing
being broadcast directly from the White
House then you are not doing your job
you have decided that broadcasting the
news is not as important as your opinion
journalism right and the unfiltered news
right and we know that the horse about
MSNBC if we know that about places like
Salon HuffPo Young Turks of course right
and a lot of people know people didn't
expect that from CNN for a long time up
into this last election and II can go
back to this rate to back when I was
syndicated on radio I talked about this
my first broadcast ever and I talked
about him in Fox News I think he would
go back to 2014 when this show was was
syndicated on radio if I'm not mistaken
I said listen I don't have a problem
MSNBC I don't have a prom with Rachel
Maddow I don't have a problem with
political bias just don't lie to me
about it and the reason that these
mainstream news outlets are refusing to
run these press briefers is because that
prohibits them from lying about it yeah
it almost ends up being free campaign
speeches for Donald Trump because he is
young a good job and because we are
seeing positive data nobody else is
reporting it he uses these press
briefings as an opportunity to get in
front of the American people and say
here's what's actually happening yeah
right and I don't think enjoy helping
him win really and if he came off
looking like a buffoon they would want
to show it of course they would get into
the room you know but instead they want
to pull out clips out of context two
minutes and like a brain here's think I
don't think that I've missed a single
briefing outside of last night actually
he very rarely actually mentions 20/20
or his polls did you hear mention that
at all tonight yeah did you hear mention
his chances in 2020 at all did you hear
mention his polls at all the one thing
was asked about the poll where 80% of
Americans and I don't know if I get 80%
80% of it
port some kind of a moratorium on
immigration right now yeah which sounds
about right that may be a right-leaning
poll to be fair but I still think that a
vast majority of Americans probably
support this right now when they look at
in future employment prospects he
actually diverted away from he said well
listen I didn't know about the poll
that's not and he answered very clearly
he had an opportunity at that point to
say yes I went by the polls and I'm
doing great at the post instead he said
this wasn't a decision made based on
polls
unlike the Clinton camp the Clinton
presidency which was entirely dictated
by polls which explain your interest by
the way newt newt gingrich led house um
he had the opportunity to go out to
flaunt his poll numbers good or not
right discuss them and we do have some
poll numbers coming out that are pretty
good instead he avoided it he
sidestepped and actually if i'm not
mistaken he gave the floor again to dr.
Burks he did and one of the things that
he tweeted out today was that he he
addressed the poll controversy because
people are like what are you talking
about your poll numbers for not poll
numbers for sorry the the raine great in
brazil right he said look the only
reason I'm mentioning that is because
the fake news media won't cover me I'm
trying to get around them and get
information to the American public I'm
not saying and as good things are doing
well because I'm trying to build myself
up I mean I'm sure he has some kind of
motivation there was like this is great
this feels good but at the same time
he's saying guys people want to watch
this and you're refusing to let them
because it doesn't push the narrative
that you and you know what else I've
really noticed from these briefings and
people are gonna get mad at me for
saying this and this could be a right up
at Media Matters but I really don't care
it shows you that the leftist move this
right-hander's to the lowest common
denominator no time a matter that they
pander to the lowest common denominator
meaning people 47% of American Americans
who don't pay income taxes federal
income taxes they pander to the
percentage of Americans who actually
stand to make more who have been
perpetually serially on unemployment
indefinitely who are now going to get an
extra check they want those people they
need those votes Donald Trump is talking
to and this is what kind of it shook up
Michigan and surprise me I've never been
more wrong in my life where I thought
Donald Trump could never win Michigan
but the fact is most Americans want to
work most Americans don't want to suckle
at the public tea most Americans want to
be productive most Americans want to
earn their keep and these press
briefings are directly aimed at those
Americans not the Americans who are
looking to scale
by on a handout and people will try and
say that comes with all connotations no
I'm just talking about the numbers if
you look at all of the online articles
you look at the online news outlets
let's call them that you even look at
the mainstream news outlets they are
talking they create this sort of dynamic
where it's like most Americans don't
want to go back to work and most
Americans want to stay at home and
Donald Trump this is a very risky bet
when you watch these briefings and
that's why I encourage everyone to watch
these briefings we even talked about
just live-streaming them on crowder bit
so you can watch them every night I know
it's not really what we do because we
are not journalists I'm not a journalist
I am biased I'm I'm a late-night
comedian I want to be very very clear
about that but we've thought about doing
it because it is very important that
this message gets out to the Americans
who want to work and that's a gamble
that he's making Donald Trump is betting
on the fact that this broadcast will get
out to the Americans who make up the
American labor force who made up the
single most comprehensive full
employment as he called it called it
which i think is actually I would use
that if I were something crafting his
campaign management if I were sorry
crafting his campaign messaging if I
were managing his campaign I would
absolutely focus on the idea of full
employment that we had before with an
unemployment numbers there were and job
participation is great and a record job
surplus is so it's not just the
unemployment numbers that Barack Obama
would try and go out and tout it's about
how many people are participating in the
labor force so that's a bet and this is
why Donald Trump seems more optimistic
than the media Donald Trump just like
I've said this before you know if
Democrats are the party of the poor well
then to be elected they required that
most Americans before if the Republicans
are the party of the rich then again by
the power of deduction
you can obviously understand that
Republicans would have a vested interest
in 50% of the country being rich Donald
Trump can only make this bet in
broadcasting to everyone unfiltered
unedited he knows that news meet are
going to take sound bites he knows that
they're going to cut clips out of
context right he could only make this
bet if he believes in the American
workforce if he believes in the American
spirit of exceptionalism and he believes
that Americans want to find a way to
keep the most vulnerable among us safe
which we all do right and Americans want
to get back to work and
earn their keep if he didn't believe
that he wouldn't broadcast these press
briefings he wouldn't do them every day
he surely wouldn't take that risk so the
very risk that he's taking inherent with
the messaging that you see in these
briefings is by itself optimistic and
listen there's a lot to be optimistic
about I know it's a hard time there are
look for the silver lining there are
many silver linings right now doesn't
mean that it's easy if there's a silver
lining it doesn't mean necessarily that
it's easy that's why you're looking for
a silver lining at this point as opposed
to and as opposed to a casing it is
surprised the things that aren't said is
the bet that Donald Trump is making he's
kind of sort of like with this show
we've talked about this work you know I
was in entertainment and in in comedy
for a long time and then was even at Fox
News for years and I was told hey listen
obviously liberals don't like this kind
of content conservatives don't like this
kind of content they just want talking
points they want Obama doomsday they do
not want to sit back and laugh and we
just had faith that there were enough
people out there who wanted to see this
kind of a program who related to this
kind of content people out there who are
conservatives who by and large are
people of faith who do want to be
politically informed but also want to be
entertained want to be able to watch a
late-night show and not be gut-punched
this was a gamble that we made and you
guys made it worth it you guys out there
you said you know what I'm going to tune
in and so we can only make that gamble
if we believe that there are enough
people out there who want this to exist
Donald Trump can only make the gamble of
these press briefings and it isn't it is
a gamble that's a change of pace by the
way if he believes in the American
spirit and that's why the media doesn't
want to broadcast it because they don't
that's my takeaway thank you guys so
much for tuning and again the promo code
is quarantined $30 off for the entire
month of April with the quarantine of
course tomorrow morning at 10:00 a.m.
Eastern we will be doing good morning
Mudd Club we're doing that through the
end of April Dan Crenshaw is going to be
on the show we will see you tomorrow
hopefully I'll get some sleep I got to
land this plane bye
I know
she finally made me realize
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna be alright you may take a few
days I'm gonna be alright good good yeah
[Music]
Yuni grasses
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
guards